at just after midday today essex police
were called to reports of a stabbing in
eastwood road north leon sea
the response of the emergency services
to this incident was immediate
and our officers arrived on scene within
minutes
when they arrived they found sir david
amis mp
who had suffered multiple injuries
this was a difficult incident but our
officers and paramedics from the east of
england ambulance service worked
extremely hard to save sir david
tragically he died at the scene
a 25 year old man was arrested
immediately at the scene on suspicion of
murder
he remains in custody
a knife was also recovered at the scene
the investigation is in its very early
stages
and is being led by officers from the
specialist counterterrorism command
we made it clear at the time of the
incident that we did not believe there
was any immediate further threat to
anyone else in the area
it would be for investigators to
determine whether or not this is a
terrorist incident
but as always they will keep an open
mind
today is a tragic day for the family and
colleagues of sir david
the community of south end and indeed
for the whole of greater essex
to david has dedicated his life to
serving the communities of essex and
south end
and today he was simply dispensing his
duties when his life was horrifically
cut short
i know the residents of essex of south
and west will stand with me today in
remembering a member of our community
here at essex police officers right
across our force and particularly in
south end have enjoyed a long-standing
and positive working relationship with
sir david
and today's events will be hard to take
for everyone who knew him
specially trained family liaison
officers are providing support to his
family today
our officers will continue to work
around the clock to ensure justice is
delivered for to david and his family
and i'd like to thank the people of
south end for their understanding as the
investigation continues
i would urge anyone who has any
information in relation to this terrible
incident to call essex police on 101
online or indeed via crime stoppers
finally i ask for everybody to respect
the privacy of sir david's family at
this really difficult time
and fi and lastly to say that my
personal thoughts having worked with sir
david and of course all of
those from essex please and our prayers
are with sir david and his family at
this difficult time thank you